whitaker i have been babysitting for 20
years i've seen it all
the thing is uh forrest is a unique
child
everything is gonna be fine i want you
to have a good time tonight you deserve
it
okay um good luck
thank you
oh god guy
oh hey there forest
google guy guy i want
i want milk you want me to get your
bottle buddy
i want milk okay
[Music]
this is a baba i want mama's milk
why can't i have mama's milk it's a
simple request
what yeah well uh you should you can't
have mama's milk right now
buddy um how about we play okay
i want i want i want to play with my
legos
okay yeah okay buddy let's uh get your
legos done
i wanna i wanna put the smallest lego
in my mouth that's all i'm gonna do no
no you can't you can't do that
first you tell me i can't have mama's
milk now
became a smallest lego in my mouth what
a night
this is a bad start rapid force it's
dangerous
let me get this straight you're in
charge of me
in my house all right forest it's time
for bed i guess then
you're gonna sing me a song what
mama always sing me a song before i go
to sleep
are you gonna do that for me okay okay
yeah
yes i will hush little baby
don't say a word keep
keep singing mama's gonna buy you a
mockingbird
put my name in it i like i like it
personal
hush baby forest whitaker don't
say a word
mama's gonna buy you a mockingbird
good babysitter and if that mockingbird
don't sing have a good cry my mama's
gonna buy
[Music]
you
you